In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for June 24th, on which we commemorate St. Athanasios
of Potos.
Born of devout parents on the island of Potos in 1722, our Holy Father Athanasios received
his earliest education in his homeland and in various schools scattered around the islands.
nourishing a burning desire to increase his knowledge, he was entered in 1745 in the famous
Evangelical School of Smyrna, where he remained for six years.
He went then to the Athonias, the Academy founded on Mount Athos, which had the purpose
of a lying encyclopedic teaching with Orthodox tradition in the integral form in which it
was preserved on the Holy Mountain.
Thanks to the teaching of the two great scholars of the period, Neofitos of Kapsokalavia
and Eugenios Bulgaris, one of whom succeeded the other as director of the Athonias, Athanasios
slaked his thirsting spirit with learning.
He excelled in all the disciplines, especially in the study of the Holy Scripture and preaching.
He was appointed a teacher in 1757, his reputation rapidly growing beyond Athos.
He was soon given the direction of the School of Thessalonica.
He shone for four years in this charge, 1758 through 1762.
Not only by his teaching but also by his sermons, vibrant with faith and trust in God, which
gained him the affection of the people.
A plague epidemic having brought about the school's closure, he went to Kourfu, where he became
a student once more, to complete his studies in philosophy, physics, and rhetoric with
Nikaferos Tautoki, one of the most cultivated churchmen of his time.
He was appointed then to Mesolongion, to teach in the school founded by his fellow disciple
and friend Panagyotis Palamas, he made a great contribution to the development of this school,
which preserved an excellent reputation until the 1821 Revolution.
In 1771, he was named Dean of the Athonias by the Patriarchate, and for six years entered
into the heritage of Eugenius Mulgaris, ordained priest by St. Macarius of Corinth, who was
then living on Mount Athos, despite resistance on his part through humility, he contributed
together with St. Nicolemos to the program of publishing and restoring of the sources of
Orthodox spirituality promoted by the Holy Hierarch, which has rightly been termed a Filocalic
Renaissance.
This is why when the quarrel flared up about the commemoration of the departed on Sundays
and frequent communion, he allied himself with all his ill to those who were scathingly
called Colibades.
St. Macarius, St. Nicolemos, James of the Peloponnese, Neôfitos of Kavso-Calavía, Christopher
Prôdromites, and Agapios of Cyprus.
This quarrel went far beyond ritual details.
What was in question was, in fact, the defense of the Church's tradition against the secular
spirit produced by the Europe of the Enlightenment, which was beginning to spread in certain circles
of the Greek elite in Constantinople.
Shamefully slandered, the Colibades were removed from office and exiled to various places.
They did not, however, stop confessing the faith and traditions received from the Holy
Fathers and their exile providentially became the spur for a profound movement of renewal
in Thessaly, Appyrus, the Peloponnese, and especially the islands of the Aegean.
After his deposition, St. Athanasios wrote a vibrant Apologia, so convincing that he was
declared innocent in 1777.
Shortly after having been restored to his ministry, he was called upon to resume functioning
again.
He was even offered the direction of the patriarchal school of Constantinople, enticing him
with the prospect of a promise of episcopal consecration.
He gave a flat refusal declaring that he preferred the quiet of monastic life and the service
of the people of God in his homeland to glory and material gain.
He therefore resigned and set sail for Pados.
He heard while at sea of the outbreak of the Russian-Turkish war, and the ship had to put
in at heels.
Athanasios withdrew to a tiny monastery on the island, awaiting in Isikia the right moment
to continue his voyage.
He was, however, soon discovered by the people living on heels.
Who asked him to take over the direction of their school?
Despite his decided refusal, they succeeded in prevailing on him, at least to teach rhetoric
until the end of the war.
During these years, he also, at the end of his courses on rhetoric, gave lessons in dogmatic
theology and logic, his teaching was so successful that when war was over, the local people
and the eminent men, supported by the ecclesiastical authorities, succeeded in overcoming the man
of God's resistance.
Obeying the purpose of providence, Athanasios directed the philosophy school of heels, till
1812, giving it such a reputation that students flocked to it from all parts of Greece, and
also from Egypt, Palestine, and even Armenia.
He taught logic, metaphysics, theology, rhetoric, and ethics, preeminently presenting a model
of perfect evangelical living.
It was only after having reached great old age that he was able to retire to a small monastery
together with several former students and disciples to find, at last, the Hisekiya that
he had desired all his life.
He wrote several books which completed the tally of his works.
These were mainly composed of apologetic treatises aimed at defending the identity of Orthodox
tradition against Western influences.
An ardent defender of tradition, Athanasios was especially concerned to preserve the Orthodox
conception of faith, confessed by the laying down of one's life and was thus one of the most
active promoters of the veneration of the new martyrs.
While he was writing a book entitled On the True Faith and the Nature of True Philosophy,
he was seized by an attack of apoplexy.
And a few days later, on the 24th of June, in 1813, he gave his soul in peace into God's
hands.
In his cell, only a simple old habit, a lamp, and an inkstan were found.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.